- I wanted to ask though about your kids.
So is it true that your daughter
is giving you music education?
Is this happening?
- Yeah.
- How so?
- I'm weak. I'm so weak for her.
It's so bad. Ugh.
Like, I taught her some old school music
that I grew up on and
I hope that she would.
So I introduced her to like
"Candy Girl" by New Edition.
Right.
And you know, the highlight
of my year last year,
is she got into the car
and she said, "Dad, can
you play Candy Girl?"
(Kelly laughing)
- [Kelly] Tear.
- I was just like, "Yeah,
I got you. I got you."
(Kelly laughing)
And then she asked for like Blank Space.
and you know, other songs.
And so, yeah.
And so in my car, like, it'll play that
and then it'll play other
songs in that genre.
Right.
And some of your music comes on.
- Yeah. It's Pop, yeah.
- So it's amazing because
I'll drop her off at school
and then I'll get back in the car
and I am singing full throttle
to like Ariana Grande's "The Way".
And I'll stop at a light
and I'm jamming and I'll look over
and the person is looking
at me and I'm like...
- [Kelly] That's right.
(Kelly laughing)
That's right.
- I used, I used to, I
used to be a sex symbol.
I'm sorry.
- [Kelly] I used to be cool.
I used to be so cool.
- But I love this music.
- Now I'm jamming.
- I don't know what it is,
but it makes my daughter smile
and happy, so it works for me.
- And it reminds you of, so I-
- Yes, it reminds me of them.
- I drop my kids off and they
like to listen to Encanto
right now, the whole soundtrack.
- Oh, that movie's incredible.
- [Kelly] It's so incredible.
So like, I drop them off
and I get back in the car.
- [Michael] Bruno.
- I'm still listening to it.
And I'm like sitting there doing Bruno
like while people are out.
And I'm like "Yeah that's
right I'm singing it."
- I'm singing Bruno all day.
- It's so good.